be fruitful yeah yeah what a weird week
LeBron came and you know what and when
LeBron came right I'm like I thought I
thought he was already here you'll never
get it right by the way cuz yesterday he
came home why and I sort of got maybe
was a LeBron LeBron a LeBron James
I don't you LeBron James yeah I can't I
[ __ ] up the first part you know he says
LeBron yeah yeah yeah yesterday he was
like babe you're Billa bro yeah and then
unko easy go easy is gonna come cowy
cowy yeah who is he's gonna come easy
yeah Drake is you yeah you do something
else me not with a new album called
scorpion that's what this to work it's
great to partner he talks about his kids
only an emotionless he does yeah yeah so
that's how I got me oh wow he's not come
to the Lakers oh yeah now let me ask you
something does that make me because I
don't know I mean I know how basketball
is played do you like this board at
first or not whatever
I played NBA Jam and whatnot yeah the
video games yeah I I've never been
really that into it to be honest with
you give it a try I'll tell you the
reason why though I want to know because
aside from Jeremy Lin and Yao Ming just
we don't my people don't play it the way
soccer because we play it
internationally yes no not
internationally when G super played for
men you son plays for Tottenham the all
the whole national team that did the
goalkeeper might go to Liverpool now we
play it and we're and also we're good so
it's if if if the sport was like a like
maybe there was like seven Asian guys in
the NBA and doing well
don't be like oh then why don't you
watch baseball so boring I can't do it
it's so slight a light pop Bali playoffs
that's all I care about
loose ball is a great dream pops born
all day
leave on your TV and just go about your
day I love it so nice to hear it in the
background or when you go and you know
you have four hours to enjoy something
with your family and friends it's like a
it's like a family affair I've been to
bath elevator music is what it is no you
eat peanuts you know you say
seventh-inning stretch it sort of it's
like a it feels there's something that's
talent okay but for a guy that doesn't
like to talk to other people though so
what I'm there alright you don't talk to
other people you just talk to who you're
there way exactly I don't talk to
anybody even the person I'm with their
own well so like let's say you and I are
there it's the ninth inning stretch or
whatever six in the seventh seventh
whatever it is right and nothing's going
on right and I'm eating pop pepper what
did they get it you said Pepsi or Pepsi
I had peanuts Pepsi price and fries and
I'm like so what's up babe no I'm not
see what's up she's like yeah it's cool
it's nice out huh yeah you think it's
boring until you really invest in a few
players and you see one of those just
one time you need to see that play or
that you like hit home run that's what
while you're in Chavez Ravine it's the
greatest feeling ever
it's so exciting I think it's better
live it's kind of like soccery like you
wait you wait for soap for a long match
and maybe they'll score maybe they won't
the resources are amazing I love you but
this is the reason why it's not the same
you because suckers one continuingly
there they're constantly in motion
you know stalkers not about scoring
it's about fluidity and them and how
they pass and how the communication
between the players it's constantly
moving so for me it's like wow what a
great save or that got that defender
really blocked you know or he got back
there or man Messi just went through six
people didn't score but it's constantly
moving it's entertaining in that way
when you see a team that's good
defensively you know when you see a good
often it's it's just more it's
entertaining to me but um the reason I
don't like baseball it's this constant
stopping they stop people are chewing
things yeah what it's exciting for me
from start to finish I know but I'm
sorry I can't I'll try the season just
long to the playoffs are fun for me but
season so long
[Music]